taxes are different this year take a
look at this chart which shows
individual income taxes collected by the
IRS there's a dramatic spike every year
in April but not so in 2020 that's
because the deadline to file individual
income taxes was delayed due to the
corona virus it's now July 15th this is
just one of several changes that could
make this year's filing even trickier
than usual here's what you need to know
going into this unprecedented tax season
the first changes this year are in the
deadlines and not just the ones for
individual income taxes so there's
dozens and dozens of deadlines in the
tax code for estimated tax payments for
estate tax payments for payroll deposits
all sorts of things that create this
constant churn of money going into the
government so the government is done is
basically D'Lite a lot of those things
push them back to July 15 this year you
can still seek an extension through
October 15th but you still have to pay
by the July 15th deadline penalties and
interest begin to accrue on July 16th
unless the date is extended again now
this deadline is for taxes on 2019
income but for many there are changes to
2020 income - if you're one of the
millions of people who received
additional money from the government
this spring know that some of it will be
taxed and some of it won't around 159
million Americans received one-time
payments between April and June of 2020
according to the Treasury Department
these were deposits of up to $1,200 for
individuals plus an additional $500 for
each child it's not taxable income and
you shouldn't
Oh anything on top of it think about it
like an additional twelve hundred
dollars added to the refund that you
were going to get in early 2021 and
they're just giving it to you now but if
you're one of the tens of millions of
people who received unemployment
benefits from the government you'll
likely have to pay tax on that money in
2021
if you're in this group you should
receive a 1099 G form early next year
that will show the amount that you were
paid in 2020 and any withheld taxes
the IRS also says to expect delays if
you're one of the millions looking for
help from the agency this tax season
many IRS offices closed down the spring
forcing staff to work remotely they were
in the middle of the busiest season of
the year and Congress basically said
okay pause that switch and do this other
thing now and get all this money out oh
and by the way do that as much as we're
possible by well not being in the office
the result big delays in customer
service and even refunds since March the
agency received a backlog of some 10
million pieces of mail and now has to
play catch-up it's warning that there
will be significant wait times for phone
calls the IRS started bringing some
employees back in late April but as of
early May 30% of workers were still out
it just means that every every
interaction you would think to have with
them is going to take longer than it
normally would but the IRS is also
cutting Americans some slack the agency
paused some compliance measures to
provide temporary relief to those
falling behind the IRS has done what
it's called people first initiative
which postpones a lot of enforcement
actions through at least through July 15
for now the idea really is just to
relieve any pressure at least
temporarily from non-compliance it
doesn't make those debts go away by any
stretch of the imagination but all of
the enforcement of the IRS would do it
it's paused for example taxpayers on a
pre-existing installment plan have the
option to suspend payments between April
1st and July 15th the IRS is also
temporarily holding back on liens and
other enforcement steps related to
unpaid tax liabilities and if you need a
new passport the IRS wants in the names
of taxpayers dubbed seriously delinquent
to the State Department during this
grace period in normal times the State
Department can delay your application or
renewal if you're way behind on your
taxes the coronavirus reshaped American
life virtually overnight and taxes were
no exception